ASSEMBLY GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION TO ORDER. WELCOME
EVERYONE TO THE COMMITTEE
HEARING. TO START I'D LIKE TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF THAT HAVE
MADE A RETURN TO THE CAPITOL TO
HEAR BILLS POSSIBLE AND ALL THE
WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THAT DUE
TO THE CONTINUED STAY AT HOME
ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. THROUGH ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE- HERE IN PERSON
WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING THAT MASS
B. WARREN PHYSICAL DISTANCING
BE MAINTAINED BY ANY INDIVIDUAL
PROVIDING COMMENT WHETHER HERE
IN THE ROOM OR THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE ROOM THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS- WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMUM. MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN.
THAT SIX FEET OF SPACING.
THERE'S ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE- HERE IN
THE ROOM. IF ANY OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO ESTIFY PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND. AND I LASTED
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN YOUR SEAT.
PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITED ELEVATOR YOU. TO PERSON
AT A TIME. FOR REMOTE WITH THIS
IN THE TO TESTIFY INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SO EMOTE
ALL. USING OUR WITH VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOMS WHICH ARE
LOCATED HERE IN THE CAPITAL-
ARE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS
AND ANOTHER LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THOSE
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM AND ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS.
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE
DILUTED WITNESSES WE WILL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANYWAY
THIS CAN TESTIFY. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY GEO COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
THE OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
BE PLACED IN THE QUEUE IF YOU
WERE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED IF YOU ARE MAIN WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY. YOUR
REMAIN ALIVE LINE IT WILL NEED
TO MEET YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE
CALLED ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE
ANY PROBLEMS WITH A MODERATE
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. TWO FIVE THREE
ONE. AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO ASSIST YOU. WITH YOUR
QUESTIONS. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGHOUT THE-
THROUGH THE POSITION THAT
LETTER PORTAL AND YOU'LL FIND
THAT ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ARE
ALL FACING. WITH THAT- RED WE
WILL PROCEED WITH THE HEARING
AGAIN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM
GRAY CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY-
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
WELCOME YOU TO THIS MORNING'S
INFORMATIONAL HERE. THE TRIBAL
STATE COMPACT BEFORE US TODAY
ARE ONES. WHICH WERE EXECUTED
IN EARLY AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
BETWEEN GOVERNOR NEWSOM ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE I'LL BAD OF
ME WALK INDIANS THE MORE TOWN
RANCHERIA MAY DO INDIANS THE
PRESS GET THE BAND OF THE
LACKEY INDIANS THE SHINGLE
SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS.
THE TELL ALL THE NAY NATION THE
TULE RIVER INDIAN TRIBE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE HAVE SIX
COMPACTS THAT WE'RE GOING. TO
BE HEARING THE DETAILS TODAY.
WE HERE THOSE THE IN THE
PRINCIPLE ARE. OF THE CON THE
OFFICE AND THE CHAIR OF THE
TRIBE. EACH CONTACT AUTHORIZE A
TRY OP. A MAX NUMBER OF SLOT
MACHINES AT A DESIGNATED NUMBER
OF GAMES. LOCATED ON ELIGIBLE
LANDS HELD IN TRUST FOR THE
TRIBE AND LOCATED WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE TRIBE'S
RESERVATION. UNDERAGE COMPACT
THE TRIBES AGREED TO PAY THE
STATE ITS PRO RATA SHARE OF
COST THE STATE AND CURSE FOR
THE PERFORMANCE OF ITS DUTIES
UNDER THE COMPACT. THE CONTACTS
INCLUDE REQUIREMENTS FOR INTER
GOVERNMENTAL AGREEMENTS BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE TRIBE
THAT ARE BINDING AND
ENFORCEABLE. WHICH REFLECTS.
THE RESPECTFUL AND COOPERATIVE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
PARTIES. THESE AGREEMENTS FOR
PAYMENTS FOR FIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AMONG OTHER THINGS TO
MITIGATE THE ARE PRESERVATION
IMPACTS OF THE GAMING FACILITY.
CERTAIN TERMS OF THESE CONTACTS
RELATED TO LICENSING REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROVISIONS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY THE SAME AS
RECENT CONTACTS WE HAD HERE
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. I'M
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THESE
CONTACTS MERE MANY OF THE
RECENT CONTACTS THAT HAVE COME
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
AREA OF ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS MEANING FOR
CONSUMER AND EMPLOYEE
PROTECTIONS. LABOR PROVISIONS
LAW WORKERS TO UNIONIZE IT HERE
AT THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE LAWS
AND A COMMITMENT BY THE TRIBES
TO REVENUE SHARING WITH NON
GAMING AND LIMITED GAMING
TRIBES AT THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS
OF GAMING CAN EXTEND TO ALL
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS DROPPED OFF
FOR. THE FACT THESE CAR WILL BE
IN FOR IN THE FOR TWO FIVE FALL
THE IF DATE. LIKE TO REMIND
DOLLARS PARTIES THAT. NO FORMAL
VOTE WILL BE TAKEN TODAY
TODAY'S HEARING IS FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TO BE BRIEFED ON THE
CONTENTS OF EACH CONTACT BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THE TRIBE AS
THEY CANNOT BE AMENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. SB EIGHT SIX NINE
MY CENTER DODD WHICH IS PENDING
IN THE ASSEMBLY IS THE
RATIFICATION BILL FOR THE SIX
CONTACTS. AND AT SOME POINT IN
THE NEAR FUTURE WILL BE TAKING
UP- THAT. SENATE BILL ON THE
FLOOR FOR CONSIDERATION BY THE
ENTIRE BODY. I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF OUR WITNESSES IN ADVANCE
FOR TAKING TIME OUT OF BUSY
SCHEDULES TO BE WITH US TODAY.
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN THE HEARING. DO
WE HAVE MISSED NAY MARK THERE
SHE IS- IN THE ROOM WITH US IF
WE COULD- HAVE YOU INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. AND GO AHEAD AND
PROCEED. WITH THE COMPACT. FOR
THE IRONMAN OF MIWOK INDIANS
THANK YOU MISTER MARK. THANK
YOU KAREN GRAY AND GOOD
MORNING- ALMOST AFTERNOON. AND
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
MY NAME IS ANNA NAY MARK AND I
AM THE GOVERNOR'S TRIBAL
NEGOTIATIONS ADVISER I WILL
SPEAK TO EACH CONTACT
INDIVIDUALLY AS IT COMES UP.
BUT I WANTED TO GIVE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW MY FIRST TESTIMONY IF.
CHAIRWOMAN IS OKAY WITH. THE
GOVERNOR HAS NEGOTIATED AND
SIGNED SIX NEW TROUBLED STATE
GAMING COMPACT THESE CONTACTS
ARE BETWEEN THE STATE. AND THE
I. OWN BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS
THE MORE TIME RENTERIA OF MAIDU
INDIANS THE SCAN TO BANTON I'M
LUCKY IN THE END THE SHINGLE
SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS.
THE TOLOWA DEE NI NATION AND
THE TO THE RIVER INDIAN TRIBE
OF CALIFORNIA. EACH OF THESE
COMPLEXES INDIVIDUALLY
NEGOTIATED AND IS UNIQUE TO
EACH TRIBE WITH THE CORE GOALS
OF SUPPORTING STRONG SELF
SUFFICIENT TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND FUNDING ESSENTIAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES TO TRAVEL
CITIZENS FOREVER REVENUES
GENERATED THROUGH THEIR
CASINOS. ECONOMIC PROVISIONS OF
THE CONTACTS YOU TO ADDRESS THE
INDIVIDUAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
MARKETS OF EACH TRIBE FOR
MAKING SURE NOT TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFIT.
ANYONE TRIED WHEN LOOKING AT
THE UNIVERSE OF COMPAQ'S. CORE
TO THIS APPROACH WAS ENSURING
THAT EACH TRIBE IS THE PRIMARY
BENEFICIARY OF THE FACILITY AS
INTENDED BY THE INDIAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT. AND THAT THE
CONTACTS PROVIDE FOR FAIR
REIMBURSEMENT FOR STATE
REGULATORY COSTS. IT IS THE
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FUND OR
STF. AS WELL AS REVENUE SHARING
TO THE REVENUE SHARING TRUST
FUND AND TRIBAL NATION GRANT
FUNDS WITH LIMITED. AND NON
GAMING TRIBES. THE I. OWN BAND
ME WALKING. COME IS THE FIRST
CALL FOR THE TRI. WHICH WILL.
AND YOU STREAM AND COVER AND
SERVICE. YEAH I DON'T. THE OF
TWELVE HUNDRED DEVICES PAID PRO
RATA STF AND PAYS NO REVENUE
SHARING FUNDS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE OTHER CORE PROVISIONS OF
THE COMPACT INCLUDING TERMS
ONLY TO LICENSING REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT LABOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
IN SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION OR SUBSTANTIALLY
LIKE THE CABINS ON COMPACT
RATIFIED BY THIS BODY LAST YEAR.
THIS SIMILARITY INCLUDES
PROTECTIONS AGAINST WORKPLACE
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT
PROVISIONS TO ADOPTING COMPLY
WITH THE FEDERAL FAIR LABOR
STANDARDS ACT INCLUSION OF THE
TRIBE WILL ADOPT THE STANDARD
TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE. THE CONTACTS ALSO
INCLUDE PROVISIONS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
MITIGATION WITH LESS INTENSIVE
PROCESS THESE IF THE TRIBE
OPERATES UNDER THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DEVICES. IRRESPECTIVE
OF THE DEVICE COUNTY
ENVIRONMENTAL PROVISIONS
REQUIRE THAT HEAD OF ANY
PROJECT THE TRIBE MUST ANALYZE
AND DOCUMENT OFF RESERVATION
IMPACTS PROVIDE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD INCOME TO
MITIGATION AGREEMENT WITH A
LOCAL OR STATE GOVERNMENT. I'D
LIKE TO THINK THE CHAIRPERSON
pIN THIS CHALLENGINGTIME. THANK
YOU AND I AM HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISSTATEMENT AT THIS TIME WE'LL
GO AHEAD MOVE UP. INTO THE
GALLERY WELCOME THE CHAIR WOMAN
OF THE WE WALK IN INTO NASCAR
TO PROVIDE HER TEST MARC THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. INTERMENT
GRAHAM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M SCARED THAT'S TEACHER
PERSON FOR THE I AM BAD AT ME
WALK INDIANS WE HAVE THE TRIBE
I THINK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TODAY
AND I'LL TRY TO KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF. I AM ENEMY WALK
INDIANS IS LOCATED IN RURAL
AMADOR COUNTY NOT TOO FAR FROM
HERE. AND IT'S AN AREA WHERE
WE'VE CALLED HOME FOR THOUSANDS
OF YEARS. WITHIN A ROLL
MEMBERSHIP OF OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY CITIZENS. WE
ARE THE LARGEST TRIBE IN OUR
REGION. AND WE ARE PRESENTLY
NOT ENGAGED IN GAMING. LIKE SO
MANY OF OUR SISTER NATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. R. TRIED HISTORY IS
QUITE TRAGIC INVOLVING A
CENTRAL ON EFFORT TO SOLIDIFY
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WITH THE UNITED
STATES. I DON'T THINK YOU'RE A
HOMELAND CAPABLE OF SUPPORTING
OUR GOVERNMENT AND OUR TRIBAL
MEMBER POPULATION. I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT THROUGH THE EFFORTS OF
SEVERAL GENERATIONS OF
LEADERSHIP AND CITIZENS WERE
ABLE TO RESTORE GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE UNITED STATES NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR. AND JUST ON MARCH
TWENTIETH OF THIS YEAR WE
RESTORED OUR VERY FIRST TRIBAL
TRUST LANDS TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
ACRES IN AMADOR COUNTY RIGHT
OUTSIDE THE CITY OF PLYMOUTH.
OF COURSE THESE LONG EFFORTS
HAVE NOT COME OUT COME WITHOUT
A SIGNIFICANT COST. HIGH
PROPERTY VALUES IN OUR REGION
COMBINED WITH THE COST TO
UNDERGO THE FEDERAL FEE TO
TRUST PROCESS. AND HERE'S A
LITIGATION DEFENDING ARE
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED STATUS AND
OR RATE TO RESTORE A LAND BASED.
HAVE LEFT US WITH CONSIDERABLE
DEBT. FURTHER A BLOCK OF LAND
BASED AND SUFFICIENT FUNDING
AND HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
CONSTRAINED OUR EFFORTS TO
DEVELOP CRITICAL PROGRAMS AND
RESOURCES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR CITIZENS. RIVAL GAMING IS
OUR ONLY HOPE FOR MEETING OUR
OBLIGATIONS AND BEGINNING TO
BUILD A ROBUST IN SUPPORT OF
TRIBAL GOVERNMENT THAT OUR
CITIZENS DESERVE. TODAY I URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT OUR
RECENTLY NEGOTIATED AND AGAIN
VERY FIRST TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT. THAT WE'RE THE ONLY
TRIED SPEAKING WITH YOU TODAY
THAT IS NOT ALREADY ENGAGED IN
GAMING. WE ARE NO STRANGERS TO
THE PASTA IN COMPACT THAT
TRIBAL GAMING HAS HAD ON THE
COMMUNITY. GAMINE VASTLY
CHANGES THE ECONOMIC CLIMATE
AROUND TRIBAL LANDS IT CREATES
JOBS AND SECONDARY REVENUE
BENEFITING NOT ONLY IN INDIA
COUNTRY. BUT OUR NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES. ONLY REVENUE
GENERATED FROM GAMING
OPERATIONS ALLOW STRIVE TO
DEVELOP PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
THEIR CITIZENS GENERAL WELFARE
SOCIAL SERVICES EDUCATION
ESSENTIAL SERVICES PROTECTION
OF CULTURAL RESOURCES. AND
ALLOWS US TO SISTER NON TRIBAL
NEIGHBORS THREW GRANT OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE. THESE ARE
PRECISELY THE SAME GOALS WE
HOPE TO ACHIEVE WITH OUR OWN
GAMING OPERATIONS. AT THE END
BRIEFLY MENTIONED COMPACT
AUTHOR UP TO TWELVE HUNDRED
CLASS THREE GAMING MACHINES AS
WELL AS VARIOUS OTHER FORMS OF
GAMING. ITSELF FORTH MEANINGFUL
CONSUMER PROTECTION. EXCUSE ME
CONSUMER AND EMPLOYEE YOU
PROTECTIONS IT CONTAINS
PROVISIONS FOR THE MEDICATION
OF OFF RESERVATION IMPACTS OF
THE GAMING FACILITY. IT
DEMONSTRATES OUR STRONG
COMMITMENT TO REVENUE SHARING
THROUGH THE R. S. T. F. AND
TRIBAL NATION GRANT FUND IN
FUTURE YEARS FUNDS THAT WE HAVE
DEPENDED ON VERY SIGNIFICANTLY
AS A NON GAMING TRIBES FOR A
LONG TIME. IT REFLECTS THE
TRIBES PLEDGE TO SUPPORT AND
INVESTMENT IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY FOR IMPROVED
EMERGENCY SERVICES LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT. ALL DESIGNED TO
BENEFIT THE AMADOR COUNTY
COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE. AND OF
COURSE THE COMPACT PROVIDES THE
TRIBE WITH THE MEANS OF
GENERATING REVENUE THAT WE CAN
USE TO ESTABLISH. LONG TERM
ECONOMIC SELF SUFFICIENCY AND
PROSPERITY FOR TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT AND FOR OUR CITIZENS.
GAMING OPERATIONS WILL GENERATE
REVENUE THAT WE WILL USE TO
SUPPORT OUR SOCIAL AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS HOUSING
HEALTH CARE AND THE
PRESERVATION OF OUR CULTURAL
RESOURCES. I THINK THAT WE HAVE
STRUGGLED AND WE STILL STRUGGLE
TO MAINTAIN. THIS IS INDEED A
VERY EXCITING TIME FOR THE
TRIBE. I'D LIKE TO THANK
GOVERNOR NOOSES OFF NEWSOME'S
OFFICE AND IN PARTICULAR IN A
MARK FOR HER PROFESSIONALISM
AND INTEGRITY AS WE WORK TO
COME TO AGREEMENT ON THE
CONTACT. AS WELL AS THE TWENTY
GENERAL'S OFFICE FOR THEIR HARD
WORK IN HELPING US TO FINALIZE
THE COMPACT. IT ALSO LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE ONCE AGAIN
FOR YOUR ATTENTION TODAY AND
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT. THE I AM
BANNED ME WALK INDIANS TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACT. THIS IS
THE FIRST OF WHAT I HOPE TO BE
MANY DISCUSSIONS WITH MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE AS WE WORK TO
DEVELOP A STRONG GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SURE AT THIS
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO TURN TO
THE FOR TYPE THAT WE GOT TESTED
FROM JACK REYES REPRESENT YOUR
HERE INTERNATIONAL YOU SO
OPERATORS YOU COULD GO AHEAD
AND PUT MISTER GRIFFIN. I'M
HERE. WELCOME MISTER GRIFFIN GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED WITH YOUR
QUESTION. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
GRAY TO YOU AND TO THE REST OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS- WE'RE
HERE TO AND WHILE I MAKE THIS-
AN OVERALL STATEMENT SO I'M NOT
WASTING A BUNCH OF YOUR TIME
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE I.
OWN BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS
CONTACT AS WELL AS MORE TOWN
RANCHERIA OF MY DO INDIANS. THE
BEST GET THE BAND OF- NON MACHI
INDIANS THE SHINGLE SPRINGS
BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS THE TO
ALLAH MEETING THE NATION AND
THE TRULY RIVER INDIAN. AND
WE'RE HERE SUPPORT THEM
BECAUSE- ONE THEY CERTAINLY
DESERVE THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
TRAVEL GAMING PROVIDE. IN
CALIFORNIA- ALSO- AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF UNITE HERE
THE HOTEL AND CASINO WORKERS
UNION WHERE WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS EIGHT
THOUSAND A POEM HAVE WORKED- IN
TRAVEL CASINOS ALTHOUGH HALF OF
OUR MEMBERS NATIONALLY LITTLE
ACTUALLY. ARE NOT WORKING AT
THE MOMENT IT'S OUR HOPE THAT
ALL THIS HARD WORK BETWEEN THE
STATE AND THE TRIBES- WILL-
STATUS SHOP FOR ANY SOLID RE
OPENING IN BACK TO WAIT. TEN
BILLION DOLLAR- TRIBAL GAMING
INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA- WE VERY
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
RESPECT. FOR THE WORKERS WHO
WERE THE ENGINE BEHIND THIS
INDUSTRY AND THE- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE IN
THESE CONTACTS. THAT PROVIDE
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION AND
FREEDOM OF ASSOCIATION- FOR-
WORKERS IN THESE CASINOS. BUT
THE POINT. THAT DO YOU CAN OF A
GREEN ONLY WORK WHEN THEY GOOD.
AND THE FACT THAT WE EIGHT
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND THE TRAVEL.
INDUSTRY AND CAL MEAN THAT WE
IN VERY GOOD FAITH AND TRY OF
WORK VERY VERY GOOD FAITH WE
THEIR WORK FORCES. IN OF A OF
THE PARTICULARLY IN CALIFORNIA
OVER THE AND WE'RE HOW. THAT
THAT KIND OF GOOD FAITH WILL
INTO. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IF YOU
NEED ME TO SAY ANYTHING MORE ON
STAND ON THE PHONE BUT I DIDN'T
WANT TO WASTE YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MISTER DRIVEN AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS WOULD GO AHEAD AND MOVE
TO. PUBLIC COMMENT AND I SEE WE
HAVE. TESTIMONY OF THE DOLLAR
AND WILL BEGIN THEIR- THERE.
YEAH WHAT'S HAPPENING IS IT'S
GOOD. DO WE HAVE A WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
THE PHONES- OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN
NOT TO ONE AND THEN ZERO YOU
JUST MOMENT MISTER CHAIR FOR
FIRST COMMON OVER THE PHONE.
DID WE HAVE ANY. PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THE PHONE LINES. WE DO A
CONCERN LINE TWENTY FOUR LINE
TO FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SUSAN%
JOHNSON I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONS INDIAN GAMING
ASSOCIATION. THE ASSOCIATION
REPORTS THESE UNIQUE COMPACTS
THAT HAVE BEEN AGREED UPON BY
EACH TRIBAL GOVERNMENT. AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MISTER
JOHNSON. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS- COMING THROUGH THE
PHONE LINES. NINE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME WILL MOVE TO THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOMS AND SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES- ARE
PREPARED TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK.
TO THE MEMBERS FOR ANY.
QUESTION THE FOLKS THAT HAVE-
TESTIFIED HERE MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN HAS
WANTED- THANK CHAIRMAN DUSKY-
SHE WORKED ON THIS FOR A LONG
TIME WE APPRECIATE IT AND
SPITTLE HARD WORK FILE AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU AND
CONGRATULATIONS. IT'S ABOUT
TIME. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS. MR
COOLEY. WELL HAVING JUST MOVED
MY SON AND HIS WIFE TO SEE A
SHINGLE SPRINGS IT'S GOOD TO
HAVE THAT- FOUR ONE ONE THAT
IMPORTANT NEWS TODAY LIKEWISE
OF. WHERE'S MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
BIGELOW ACTUALLY REPRESENTS THE
ME WALK MY OWN BAND AREA WITHIN
HIS DISTRICT IS RIGHT ACROSS
THE BORDER FROM MY DISTRICT
WEATHER ONE SEVEN ON JACKSON
ROAD I OWN ORDER TWIN CITIES
ROAD. FOR LIKEWISE IT'S GOOD TO
SEE THAT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
CRICKET PRECIADO FOR PERSON
TOUCH KEYS. RECITAL OF THE
HISTORY OF THE MILESTONES AND
ALL THE LABOR SINCE THE
IMPORTANT BREAKTHROUGH IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. VERY
IMPORTANT- ON MATTERS BEFORE
THE STATE THANK YOU. BACK TO
MISTER COOPER AND I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T SAY- SOME
GOOD THINGS ABOUT SHINGLE
SPRINGS OBVIOUSLY FROM BEING A
SECOND LITTLE BOY. IN HER MIND
TIRE LIFE AND HAD THE UP TO
WORK SPRINGS. ON THE VERSA. AND
IT'S A LONG TIME TO FOR THEM
ALL SO. IT'S BEEN A SLOW
PROCESS FOR EVERYBODY- BUT IT'S
GOOD TO SEE SOME ISSUES. SO HAD
A VERY VERY GOOD SHINGLE
SPRINGS. THANK YOU FOR COOPER.
ANY COMMENTS QUESTION FROM MY-
SEEING NONE- I'M GONNA BRING IT
BACK. WELL FIRST OF ALL
CONGRATULATIONS- GERMAN. BEST
WISHES TO THE TRIBE ON THE
CHEATING THIS- CONTACT WITH THE
STATE WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THIS- ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR IN THE NEAR FUTURE. THIS
TIME I'M A RETURN TO- MISNAMED
MARK AND- GIVEN- OUR LIMITED
SPACE AND TIME HERE DURING THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS WILL GO
AHEAD AND ENTER MR GRIFFEN'S
COMMENTS INTO THE RECORD FOR
ALL OF THE- CONTACT BEFORE US
WHICH I THINK WAS HIS INTENTION
AND I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
FOR THE COMMITTEE- FIRST DATA
GO THROUGH IN ORDER- HAVE YOU
FOCUS AND NOT ON THE TERMS THE
CONTACT THAT ARE. VASTLY
SIMILAR BUT RATHER ANY SPECIFIC
NEW WANTS IS YOU THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE MEMBERSHIP
BE AWARE OF PRIOR TO
CONSIDERING THIS- ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND OF COURSE
WILL ALSO TAKE TESTIMONY FROM
THE CHAIRS OF EACH DRIVE ON THE
SPECIFIC. IMPAX WE'RE GOING TO
SEE. WITH THE COMPAQ FROM THE
FOR. WITH MORE TOWN. OF MAY TWO
INDIANS AND YES THEY MARK
PLEASE. GIVE A ANY NEW OR SPELL.
THAT WE SHOULD BE AWARE. APPS
JAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT THE
MORE TO RICHARD OF MY INDIANS
WITH NEW. AT OF THEIR EXPIRING
NINETEEN NINETY NINE COMPACT
ALLOWING THEM TO CONTINUE
GAMING THE MORE TOWN COMPACT
HAS A MAXIMUM OF TWO THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DEVICES HE'S
PRO RATA STF HAS NO REVENUE
SHARING UP TO TWELVE HUNDRED
DEVICES PAY 6% NET WHEN WITH
80% CREDITS BETWEEN TWELVE
HUNDRED AND ONE EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED DEVICES. AND 6% NET
WHEN IT'S 65% CREDITS FROM
1-800-122-2000 TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DEVICES. THE CREDITS IN
THE MORE TOWN- RANCHERIAS
COMPACT INCLUDE MUTUALLY
BENEFICIAL ITEMS LIKE RENEWABLE
ENERGY FIRE AND THE TRIBE
PROVIDES A LOT OF FIRE SUPPORT
FOR THE COMMUNITY. AND MEDICAL
SERVICES AND OTHER INVESTMENTS
IN THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY-
INSTEAD OF INCLUDING MINIMUM
STANDARDS IN THE COMPACT FOR
TOR PROTECTION PATRON DISPUTE
AND HARASSMENT DISCRIMINATION.
THE COMPAQ'S APPEND THE TRIBES-
OWN ORDINANCES THAT PROVIDED
SORT OF THE SAME MINIMUM
PROTECTIONS- AND. RECOURSE IN
THOSE AREAS. THAT'S ALL THANK.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU MISTER
RECORD THIS DO WE HAVE CHAIRMAN
CLARK WITH US FOR. TESTIMONY
YES. EXCELLENT GO AHEAD PERCENT
OF A CHAIR UP SORRY. LOW
PERSONABLE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MET. I AM BENJAMIN BE TRY
CHAIRMAN FOR MORE CATHARINE OF
MY DOING. I WANT TO THANK
GOVERNMENT'S AND HIS NEGOTIATOR
AT I NEED MORE AND HER FOR
DEVOTING THE TIME. DURING THE
DAY THAT THE NINETEEN PANDA. TO
COLLABORATE LEE WORK THROUGH A
NUMBER OF ISSUES INTO WE FIX
THAT REACHED ON A. GAMING BEEN
KEY TO THE L. DEVELOPMENT OF
MORE CAN RANCHO. FOR NEAR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. OUR GOAL AND
ENTER INTO THE COMPACT IT
PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR THE OF
OUR- THAT. IT'LL AS WE STRIVE
CAN TO PRESS. EMPLOYEE UP. IN
THE COMMUNITY AND MAINTAIN A
CONTINUOUS SAFE OPERATION
ECONOMIC ENTERPRISES THAT HAVE
BECOME CRUCIAL TO TRIBAL
MEMBERS AND THE LOCAL COMMUNITY.
THE NEW COMPAQ WILL ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
SOCIAL EDUCATIONAL HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC PROGRAMS AND OTHER
SERVICES TO OUR TRAVEL AND
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THESE
SERVICES THAT TRULY BECOME
OFFICIALS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THE MORE
TIME RANCHERIAS COMPACT WITH
THE STATE BE APPROVED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THIS TIME
MEMBERS WILL MOVE TO- ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL GO AHEAD
AND START- HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. DO WE HAVE ANY. ONE
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT HERE IN THE WHAT
HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE PHONES
OPERATE WE HAVE ANYONE WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE PHONES. MISTER CHAIRMAN
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME ME PRESS ONE AND ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
THAT IS ONE OF THEM ZERO PLEASE.
ONE MORE TIME IN THE PUBLIC WE
HAVEN'T. WE DO HAVE ONE- IT
COMES A LINE OF TWENTY FOUR TWO
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU. I'M SORRY LINE TWENTY FOUR
IS YOUR TO HELP USE YOUR PHONE
DEVICE AND YOU. THEY
DISCONNECTED NOT NO FURTHER
COMMENTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR AT THIS TIME
WILL MOVE TO THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS DO WE HAVE.
ANYONE WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA VIDEO
CONFERENCE. SEEING NONE THAT
CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC COMMENT OR
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS
SPECIFIC CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS
AS IT RELATES TO THE COMPACT
WITH MORE TOWN RANCHERIA OF MAY
DO INDIANS. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEMBERS.
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE TRIBE THANK YOU TO MISS
THEIR MARK FOR YOUR WORK- AND
WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
THIS FOR A VOTE ON THE ASSEMBLY
FOR IN THE NEAR FUTURE. THIS
TIME OVERTURNED A COMMITMENT
FOR. THE GAMING COMPACT.
BETWEEN THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S
GOT THE BAND OF THE MACHI
INDIANS GO AHEAD WALKED US
THROUGH AND- NEW. HERE AND THEN
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE CHEST. THE
DESK BEEN OF NO MORE INDIA
COMPAQ WAS ALSO TO GO AHEAD OF
THEIR EXPIRING NINETEEN NINETY
NINE CONTACT. DISC A COMPACT
HAS A MAXIMUM TWO THOUSAND
DEVICES WITH PRO RATA STF NO
REVENUE SHARING UP TO TWELVE
HUNDRED DEVICES AND 6% NET WIN
WITH 70% CREDITS FROM TWELVE
HUNDRED AND ONE DEVICES TO TWO
THOUSAND DEVICES. THE PLACENTA
CREDITS AGAINST REVENUE SHARING
PAYMENTS ARE DEGREED UPON AS
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL USES OF
FUNDING INCLUDING FOR PROVIDING
ASSISTED LIVING FOR TRIBAL
MEMBERS. TEXTING WILDLIFE AND
HABITAT IN CONTRIBUTION THROUGH
THE TRIBES- OWN FOUNDATION THAT
THAT NO MARQUEE FIND. AND WELL
ANOTHER NEW ITEM IN THIS
COMPACT- IS THAT INCLUDES-
ADDITIONAL PROVISIONS FOR
TRIBAL CLAIMS COMMISSION TO
ADDRESS DISPUTE RESOLUTION AND
THESE COMMISSION MEMBERS HAVE
TO MEET MINIMUM ETHICAL AND
CONFLICT OF INTEREST ANDERS AND
REQUIRES A BACKGROUND CHECK
THANK YOU HAVE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME- WE'LL HEAR FROM THE CHAIR
OF THE TRIBE ON ANY. ARMATURE
SPECIFIC VERSIONS. I BELIEVE.
ANDRO HUNDRED CHAIR OF THE SCAN
TO BAND OF THE MACHI INDIANS
JOINING US VIA PHONE OPERATOR
COULD WE- GO AHEAD AND PUT THE
CHAIRMAN THROUGH. IF THE LINE
IS CONNECTED PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN AS IS
THE SPEAKER THE CHAIR HAS
CALLED ON. ONE MOMENT AS WE
GATHER THAT INFORMATION MY
APOLOGIES. LINE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING.
ANYONE CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR CHAIRMAN PLEASE PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
ARE MY NAME IS SANDRA LAWN
ITEMS THAT CHAIRMAN OF THE
TAPPED INTO A BAND OF NUMBER
LACKING. I LIKED IT YOU TO A TO
MAKE MEMBERS STADLER K. THE
TIME DURING THE- ON THE CRISIS
TO ADDRESS TRY TO COMBAT I ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ANNONAY MORE THE
GOVERNOR INTO TEAM FOR THEIR-
TO WORK TOWARD THE TRIBES
UNIQUE NEW COMP WITH PLEASED
AND- ALSO LIKE TO THANK.
SENATOR NEAL THE SETTLEMENT
GALLAGHER FOR THE INTERN
SUPPORT THROUGH THE
ENTERTAINING ARE BECOME. WHICH
WE FURTHER ENABLE US TO TRY.
ARSENAL AND MAINTAIN A BILL.
YOU CAN CONTRIBUTE OPERATE ARE
ROLLING HILLS CASINO AND GIVE
BACK TO OUR COMMUNITY I
RESPECTFULLY- IN ADVANCE THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR PROMPT PROCESSING- SB
EIGHT NINE. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
THIS TIME MEMBERS WILL MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BEGIN ON
THE PHONE LINES OPERATE WE HAVE
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU FEWEST
TO SHARE PUBLIC COMMENT OVER
THE PHONE AGAIN THAT COMMANDERS
ONE AND THEN ZERO IT WILL BE
JUST A MOMENT BEFORE FIRST
COMMENT. WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY. LINE THREE ZERO THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HELLO
SUSAN JENSEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIONS INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATION- WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ALL OF THESE
CONTACTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT VIA THE PHONE LINES AT
THIS TIME. NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU AT THIS WILL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE IT BACK TO
THE CHAMBER. ANYONE HAD THE
CHAMBER WISHING TO PROVIDE
COMMENT AT THIS TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEEING NONE WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE IT TO THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING- LOCATIONS DO WE
HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT- IN
THOSE LOCATIONS. C. NINE. OKAY
SEEING NINE- THAT CONCLUDES THE
PRESENTATION THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR ALL THE WORKS COMMENTS AS
WE SAID BEFORE WE'LL SEE THIS
ON THE FLOOR FOR A VOTE HERE IN
THE NEAR FUTURE CONGRATULATIONS.
WE'RE TURN S. NETWORK WE'RE
GOING TO NOW MOVES TO THE
CONTACTED TUESDAY CALIFORNIA
SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK
INDIANS GO AHEAD. RIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND THEN WE HEAR
FUTURE. THANK YOU THE SHINGLE
SPRINGS BAND OF MIWOK INDIANS
CONTACT WAS RENEGOTIATED TO
UPDATE THE TERMS FROM ITS
TWENTY TWELVE COMPACT TO BETTER
ALIGN WITH THE TERMS MODERN
COMPAQ'S THE SHINGLE SPRINGS
CONTACT HAS A MAXIMUM OF TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DEVICES THE 6% NET
WIN 65% CREDITS UP 220-002-0050
DEVICES AND 6% NET WHEN 60%
CREDITS. FROM TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE UP TO
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DEVICES IT
ALSO ELIMINATES ALL GENERAL
FUND PAYMENTS PAYMENTS TO THE
GENERAL FUND WERE FOUND TO BE
AN ILLEGAL TAX BY FEDERAL
COURTS AND NO OTHER TRIBES PAY
ON GOING GENERAL FUND PAYMENTS.
THE CREDITS AGAINST REVENUE
SHARING PAYMENTS THAT ARE
AGREED TO IN THIS COMPACT A
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL USES OF
FUNDING INCLUDING FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSING INTO THINGS LIKE
THE TRIBES WHITE WATER RESCUE
TEAM TO TRY TO HEALTH CARE
CENTER WHICH PROVIDES RURAL
HEALTH CARE TO THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. AND OTHER
INVESTMENTS AND THE TRIBAL AND
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS. ALSO UNIQUE
TO THIS COMPACT IS THE ABILITY
TO NEGOTIATEDIRECTLY WITH THE
COUNTY REGARDING TRAFFIC
IMPACTS AT THE DISCRETION OF
CALTRANS AND THE TRIBE. I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK THAT THE
CHAIRWOMAN FOR. CONTINUING OUR
OUR OUR NEGOTIATIONS THROUGH
THE SORT OF CHALLENGING TIMES
OF THE PANDEMIC SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISS
AMERICA AT THIS TIME OKAY GO
AHEAD MOVE TO THE CHAIR. WHO'S
JOINING US VIA THE PHONE LINE I
BELIEVE SO OPERATE IF YOU.
FOLKS PARDON ME VIDEO
CONFERENCE SO MEMBERS DIRECT
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE VIDEO
SCREENS. AND CHAIRS TESTIMONY.
WELCOME TO CHURCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS REGINA
CUELLAR AND I'M THE CHAIRWOMAN
OF THE SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND OF
MIWOK INDIANS FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE SIMPLY COMMITTEE FOR THE
HONOR OF TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THE TRIBESMEN IN CONTACT
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.I
CANNOT EXPLAIN TO YOU THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS A MINUTE
CONTACT FOR OUR TRIBE IT
FINALLY BRINGS A MEASURE OF
PARITY TO THE SHINGLE SPRINGS
BAND WHICH SIMPLY SEEKS AN EVEN
PLAYING FIELD AND THE GAMING
MARKET THAT IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY COMPETITIVE. THIS
A MANY CONTACT AND SHE WAS THAT
THE SHINGLE SPRINGS BAND HAS
FACED MORE OBSTACLES THAN MOST
CALIFORNIA TRIBES IN THE EFFORT
TO ESTABLISH GAMING THIS IS
TRUE BECAUSE OUR RESERVATION
WAS LANDLOCKED IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES WITH THE ALIGNMENT OF
AN ADJACENT HIGHWAY. WITH THE
RESERVATION THAT LACKED ANY
FORM OF PUBLIC ACCESS SINCE
THAT TIME WE HAD NO ABILITY TO
USE OUR ANSWER ANY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING GAMING
THAT CHANGE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT AS WE ARE IT FINALLY ABLE
TO DEFEAT YEARS OF LITIGATION
CHALLENGES AND SECURE PUBLIC
ACCESS. PAPER BY THE TRIBE
THROUGH SPECIFICALLY CITED
INTERCHANGE CONNECTING OUR
RESERVATION TO HIGHWAY FIFTY AS
A RESULT WE WERE ABLE TO BUILD
RED HAWK CASINO A SUCCESSFUL
WELL REGULATED AND AWARD
WINNING GAMING OPERATION SINCE
THAT TIME WE HAVE CULTIVATED
STRONG RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR
NEIGHBORS AS WELL AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SERVICE
AGENCIES. WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
HEALTH CLINIC. THAT SERVES
NATIVE AND NON NATIVE PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT EL DORADO COUNTY AND
THROUGH A VERY GENEROUS AND
WILL YOU WE CONTRIBUTE OVER TEN
MILLION TO THE COUNTY
GOVERNMENT EVERY YEAR. MOST OF
THIS MONEY IS FREE FOR THE
COUNTY TO USE AT ITS DISCRETION
BECAUSE OF OUR TRIBES MANY
CHALLENGES WE WERE FORCED TO
TAKE ON VIRTUALLY
INSURMOUNTABLE DEBT AND ACCEPT
A CONTACT FROM GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER WITH FINANCIAL
TERMS REQUIRING US TO PAY THE
STATE. 15% OF OUR NET GAMING
REVENUE IN TWENTY TWELVE
GOVERNOR BROWN HELP TO TRY
WITHIN A MINUTE AMENDMENT THAT
PROVIDED FAIR TERMS AT LEAST
FOR A TIME PERIOD THIS ENABLED
US TO PAY OFF OUR DEBT AND
BEGAN TO BENEFIT FOR MY OWN
GAMING. OPERATION WITH THIS
BILL AMENDMENTS OF YOUR BIKE
NEWSOME THOSE BURKE FINANCIAL
TERMS CAN CONTINUE BRINGING OUR
CONTACT IN LINE WITH. OTHER
OTHER TRIBAL COMPACTS IF I. BY
THE LA. THEY'VE SHE MUST BRING
DOWN ONE OH LONGER ON. AT A
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
DISADVANTAGE. THIS A MENTAL
ALSO ENABLE US TO COME TO USE
COMPACT CREDITS TO SUPPORT GOOD
AND WORTHY CAUSES THAT BENEFIT.
NATIVE PEOPLE AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS AMONG THE
OPPORTUNITIES WE CAN NOW FUND
AND SUPPORT OUR ENHANCED HEALTH
CARE AND EDUCATION. BASIC
HOUSING FOR THOSE IN NEED AN
ELDER SERVICES WE ASK AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN APPRECIATE. YOUR
TESTIMONY. THIS TIME MEMBERS
WERE GONNA MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS OR WILL RETURN TO THE
PHONE LINES AND ASK THE
OPERATOR TO. PUT THROUGH. ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME VIA
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU
AGAIN IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT TO ME PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THERE'S NO PUBLIC COMMENT
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND RETURN TO
THE CHAMBER DO WE HAVE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN THE
CHAMBER AT THIS TIME. SEEING
NONE WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE IT
BACK TO THE VIDEO. REMOTE
LOCATIONS FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENT. SEEING THAT WE HAVE
NOBODY THERE. ONE LAST CALL VIA
PHONE VIA CHAMBER THE-
VIDEOCONFERENCE FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. OKAY SEE NINE
CONGRATULATIONS THE CHAIRWOMAN
THE TRIBE THANK YOU TO THE
MINISTRATION FOR THE WORK ON
THIS AND WE'LL SEE THAT ON THE
ASSEMBLY FOR IN THE NEAR
FUTURE- FOR A FORMAL VOTE. THIS
TIME MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE
TO- THE FIFTH COMPACT ON OUR
AGENDA- THE TUESDAY CALIFORNIA
AND THAT TO LOWER THE NEED
NATION SO. MISTER THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN THE TOLOWA DEE NI
NATION COMPACT WAS NEGOTIATED
AHEAD OF THEIR EXPIRING
NINETEEN NINETY NINE COMPACT
ALLOWING THEM TO CONTINUE
GAMING. THE TELECOM PARK HAS A
MAXIMUM OF TWO THOUSAND DEVICES
WITH PRO RATTA STF NO REVENUE
SHARING UP TO TWELVE HUNDRED
DEVICES AND 6% NET WIN WITH 70%
CREDITS FROM TWELVE HUNDRED ONE
TO TWO THOUSAND DEVICES. THE
CREDITS AGAINST REVENUE SHARING
PAYMENTS WERE AGREED UPON IS
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL USES THE
FUNDING INCLUDING FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSING RECYCLING
PROGRAMS AND INVESTMENTS IN
CURRICULA AND TRIBAL LANGUAGE
AND CULTURE. ONE NEW ITEM IN
THIS COMPACT IS THAT MOST MOST
OF THE CONTACTS REQUIRED TRIED
TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO SET UP THEIR OWN
WORKERS COMPENSATION PROGRAM-
AT THE BEGINNING OF WHEN THE
CONTACT GOES INTO EFFECT OR
WHETHER THEY WANT TO PAY IT GO
INTO THE STATE WORKERS
COMPENSATION PROGRAM. THE ONE
THING THAT THE TRIBE REYES WAS
THAT MAYBE THEY WOULD LIKE TO
CREATE THEIR OWN WORKERS
COMPENSATION PROGRAM FURTHER
DOWN THE ROAD. SO WE ARE ABLE
TO WORK WITH THE TRIBE AND THAT
THE STATE LABOR AGENCY AND TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE COULD MAKE
THAT WORK AND THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO THE WE HAVE
THE CHAIR WE HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THIS FOR TESTIMONY VIA THE
TELEPHONE SO IF YOU COULD
OVERHEAD BRING THE CHAIR
THROUGH ON THE PHONE LINES.
GOOD AFTERNOON. THAT THE LAN
MCCALLUM CHAIRPERSON OF THE
FALLOUT IN THE NATION LOCATED
IN DELMAR COUNTY WE HAVE ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN TIME WORLD MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS TIME
AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE CHAIR
CHAIRMAN GREAT MEMBER COMES
BACK FOR TAKING THE TIME DURING
THE ONGOING COBRA NINETEEN
CRISIS TO ADDRESS THE TRIED TO
CONTACT. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEN WOULD FOR
THEIR INTERNET SUPPORT OF THE
TALL WHAT THE NATION AND
OBTAINING NEW COMPACT. THAT
WILL FURTHER ENABLE THE TRIBE'S.
ECONOMIC SELF RELIANCE. AND IT
ABILITY. TO BETTER THE LIVES OF
NOT ONLY OUR MEMBERSHIP BUT THE
ECONOMY AND LIVE IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AND
REGION ARE BURKE CHAU ABOUT THE
TRIBES NO MARIN PROGRAMS. AND
COMMUNITY CONTRIBUTIONS WHAT
ARE AFFORDED THE TRIBE GAMING
OPERATIONS. BUT HE SEVEN CASINO.
AND THE TAJ RELATED. THANK YOU
GOVERNOR. AND HE NAME MARK AND
THE GOVERNOR AND HIGHER
NEGOTIATING TEAM FOR THEIR
EFFORTS TO WORK WITH THE TRIAL
HONORED A COMPACT. THE TRIBE
AUGUST SEVENTH LETTER WHICH WAS
PREVIOUSLY COMMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE ALONG WITH THE TRIBE
THE PROMOTIONAL PRESHEAF AND NO
MARK LETTERS OF SUPPORT
INCLUDING SUPPORT OF. DOES NOT
COUNT AND WILL TRYING. IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO ASK. I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THE TIME THANK YOU AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU CHAIRPERSON ACCOUNT. THIS
TIME MEMBERS WILL RETURN TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBERS WISHING
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. SEEING NO ONE WILL GO
AHEAD. AND RETURN THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA PHONE OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE ONE IN Q. THERE ARE
MANY OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
QUEUE UP YOU MAY ALSO PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WELL THE TO LINE
TWENTY EIGHT TO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS PAUL YOUR
ON BEHALF OF THE DEL NORD.
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN YOU
KNOW EITHER. COMMENTING CUMAN.
THANK YOU OPERATOR THIS TIME
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CHECK THE
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOMS. SEEING NONE.
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS- SPECIFIC
TO THIS CONTACT. C. NINE WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND- SEE THIS ON
THE ASSEMBLY FOR FORMAL VOTE
SOMETIME IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
MEMBERS THIS BRINGS US TO OUR
FINAL- COMPACT REVIEW THIS
AFTERNOON. THIS LAST GAME
CONTACT INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA
TO THE RIVER INDIAN TRIBE OF
CALIFORNIA- MISNOMER. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN SIX- TO THE RIVER
INDIAN TRIBE OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONTACT WAS RENEGOTIATED TO
ADDRESS THE TRIBE'S NEW PARCEL
OF GAMING LAND. TO THE RIVERS
NEW PARCEL IS SUBJECT TO WHAT
IS CALLED A TWO PART TO
TERMINATION OR SECRETARIAL
PROCEDURES THIS IS A PROCESS
SET FORTH IN THE INDIAN GAMING
REGULATORY ACT THAT ALLOWS FOR
THE SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR
TO TAKE LAND INTO TRUST FOR
GAMING THE TRIBE FIRED AFTER
NAY EIGHTY EIGHT. IF THEY GO
THROUGH A PROCESS BY WHICH THE
SECRETARY DETERMINES THAT
TAKING LAND INTO TRUST WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO THE TRIBE AND ITS
MEMBERS AND NOT DETRIMENTAL TO
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. THE
SECOND DETERMINES THAT THIS IS
INDEED THE CASE AND REQUESTED
THAT THE GOVERNOR CAN WITH THIS
DETERMINATION AFTER EXTENSIVE
REVIEW THE GOVERNOR THE CARD
WITH THIS DECISION BECAUSE THE
POSITIVE AND ON THE TRUCK AND
ITS MEMBERS AS WELL AS THAT.
AND COMMUNITY. THE RIVER. AS
A- OF TWENTY FIVE YOUR DEVICES
WITH PROGRAM STF. PERCENT
NETWORK WITH A HIGH PERCENT. AT
THE HUNDRED. 6% NET WHEN WITH
80% CREDITS BETWEEN TWELVE
HUNDRED ONE IN EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
DEVICES. AND 6% NET WIN WITH
60% CREDITS BETWEEN EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED AND ONE AND TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED DEVICES. THE CREDITS
AGAINST REVENUE SHARING
PAYMENTS. AGREED UPON IS
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL USES OF
FUNDING INCLUDED TO PROVIDE
POTABLE- AND WATER TREATMENT TO
THE TRIBE AND LOCAL COMMUNITY.
KEY TO THE TWO PART TERMINATION
TO SUPPORT THE TRIBE'S K.
THROUGH FIVE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
AND EDUCATION DEPARTMENT. AND
TO SUPPORT THE TRIED. FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM. AT YOU
AND I AM HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. THIRTY MISTER
MAHER. AT THIS TIME MEMBERS
WILL WELCOME- CHAIRMAN NEAL
PERRON FROM THE TO THE RIVER
INDIAN TRIBE OF CALIFORNIA. AS
WELL AS KERRY PATTERSON TRIBAL
TURNEY WITH THE TO A RIVER IN
THE DRIVE CALIFORNIA. FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY. GERMAN. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES SIR WE CAN HEAR YOU
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN GRADING BY
CHAIRMAN BIGELOW AND OTHER
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NEIL BROWN
CHAIRMAN OF THE COOLER INDIAN
TRIBE CALIFORNIA. IT'S AN HONOR
TO GET THE BIKE BEFORE YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE TRIBE OF
THE POOR THAT B. EIGHT X. NINE
A BILL THAT WOULD RATIFY THE
GAMING COMPACT ENTERED INTO
BETWEEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND TO TRY. TO EXECUTED ON
AUGUST THIRD TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY IT AGAIN I WOULD LIKE TO
RIDE WITH ME BACKGROUND OF THE
TRIBE AND ITS MEMBERS
GOVERNMENT BEGINNING OPERATION.
TRY TO THE FAMILY RECOGNIZED
TRIBE WITH ONE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX MEMBERS OF
THE SITUATED ON THE TO RIVER
INDIAN RIGHT AND TULARE COUNTY
RESERVATIONS AND FIFTH OF
550-003-0090 SIX ACRES. AND IS
LOCATED APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
MILES. FROM THE CITY OF PORT OF.
INTO COUNT. THE TRUCK. PROVIDE
FULL RANGE OF SERVICES FOR
MEMBERSHIP INCLUDING EDUCATION
HEALTH HOUSING LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TRIBAL COURT SERVICES THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT AMBULANCE SERVICES.
PUBLIC UTILITIES NATURAL
RESOURCES MANAGEMENT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AND COMMUNITY
ASSISTANCE. WE ARE OPEN AND
OVER CENTER AND A BETTER AND
BETTER HERE ON THE RESERVATION.
THE TRIBE HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR TRIBAL MEMBERS OF PROPERTY
FROM THE HISTORY OF FORCED
REMOVAL AND- ADDITION. TRIBAL
LAND AND RESOURCES. ALTHOUGH
THE ON RHETORIC BUT SHORT
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS HAVE
IMPROVED. TIME RESIDENTS
CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM I'M AN
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE OF
APPROXIMATELY 40% ON
RESERVATION. AND APPROXIMATELY
44% OF TRIBAL MEMBERS. LIVE IN
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE NEAR. OR
BELOW THE- I DO MANY MEMBERS DO
NOT ACCESS TO A RELIABLE WATER
SUPPLY TO SEVERE SHORTAGES ON
THE REST OF. AS REBEL OF WATER.
THE TRIBE HAD TO PLAY MORE
TWENTY BUILDINGS. ON RESUME.
INCLUDING TRAVEL HOUSING EVEN
OF THE TRIBE A HOUSING WAITING
LIST OF OVER TWO HUNDRED FAMILY.
I TRIED TO THINK IF YOU KNOW
DISLOCATE ON A RESERVATION BUT
DUE TO THE GROWING TRIBAL
POPULATION. INCREASED DEMAND
FOR SUPPORT SERVICE AND
INFLATION OF THE PORK CHOPS. IF
YOU KNOW REPRESENT LONGER
SUFFICIENT. SEVERAL FACTORS
OPULENT THE ECONOMIC POTENTIAL
OF THE DISTINCTIVE YOU KNOW.
BETTER THIS REMOTE LOCATION THE
DANGEROUS ROAD THAT PROVIDES
THE ONLY ACCESS TO THE CASINO
AND A LIMITED. DEVELOPER AREA
DUE TO WATER SHORTAGES ON THE
RESERVATION. SB EIGHT FIFTY
NINE WRAP COMPAQ WHICH AMEND
TRIBE THOUSAND. CONTACT ORDER
TO FACILITATE THE RELOCATION OF
THE DIFFERENT. NOW TO TRAVEL WE
OWN FORTY ACRE PARCEL OF LAND.
LOCATED WITHINTHE TRIBES
ABORIGINAL TERRITORY AND THE OF
PORTABLE. PROVIDING THE
RELOCATION BY SECRETARY OF THE
UNITED STATES PART OF THE
CHAIRMANSHIP OF THE
TERMINATION. N OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN REGARDING
GAINING ELIGIBILITY AFTER THE
PATIENT BY AND ATTRACT
APPLICATION. TO PLAY FOR THE
LOCATION BY THE TRUCK. AND
GOVERNOR BAKER WITH AFFECTED
DETERMINATION ON AUGUST THIRD
TWO. TWENTY THE TRIBE HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF THE RELOCATION
BACK AT THE FIVE MILES NORTH OF
THE AND RATIFY. A FIFTY ONE
THREE. RECOGNIZE THE TRIBE. BUT
THE CITY IN A STATE RECOGNIZED
TRIBE BEING MOST CLOSELY
CONNECTED FOR HUMAN REMAINS AND
FUNERARY OBJECTS DISCOVERED
NEAR THE LOCATION.AND I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
TRIBE RESPECT WITH THIS TO TRY
AND RECEIVE NO OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION REGARDING OUR
CONTACT LARA MEDICATION. MOVING
OF THAT BECAUSE YOU KNOW TO THE
RELOCATION PACKAGE ESTIMATED TO
INCREASING ON THE RESERVATION
THE FIVE WATER BY TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE GALLONS PER DAY.
ADDITIONALLY THE RELOCATION OF
THE FIFTEENTH IF YOU KNOW THE
EXPECTED NEARLY DOUBLE THE
TRIBE'S CAPTURING THE LOCAL
GAINING MARKET REVENUES FROM
THE OPERATION OF THE FIFTEEN I
WOULD PROVIDE FUNDING FOR A
VARIETY OF HOW. HEALTH
EDUCATION SOCIAL CULTURAL AND
OTHER PROGRAMS AND SERVICES FOR
TRIBAL MEMBERS IN THE
COMMUNITY. IT ALSO PROVIDE
APPOINTED OPPOTUNITIES FOR
MEMBERS AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY. CRISTINA
RELOCATION LOCKPORT FIFTY
COUNTY UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WHICH
AS OF MAY TWENTY TWENTY.
EIGHTEEN POINT 4% THE SIXTH
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN THE
STATE RELOCATION OF THE FIFTY
ESTIMATED TO CREATE TWELVE.
HUNDRED TEMPORARY CONSTRUCTION
JOBS AND AN INCREASE OF SEVEN
HUNDRED NINETY PERMANENT JOBS.
AND REGION IN THE MARKET CAN'T.
LOOK ALONG WITH THE GAME FROM
THE AREA. YOU CONJUNCTION WITH
THE RELOCATION OF THE CASINO
THE TRIBE MATERIAL CONSTRUCTING
WATER RECLAMATION. I'M CITY ON
PROPERTY. WATER THE. THE PLACE
A PART OF THE CURRENT. BUT
BECAUSE THE PROJECT WILL
USUALLY POSSIBLE DEFENDER
CURRENTLY BEING FIGURE GATE FOR
COMPLEX WILL BE A 730-008-0020
EIGHT PER INCREASED AND POTABLE
WATER IT IN THE PORTABLE THE
TRIBE HAD PART OF THE COUNTY
AND THE CITY BUT THE REAL OF
THE IF YOU KNOW AND BEEN ROUTED
THE MEMO. OF UNDERSTAND WITH.
AND LASTLY ON A QUICK HOLD.
YEAH THE TRIBE HAS WORKING ON
THIS FOR A PROPOSAL BUT AS WE-
AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR TIME BUT WE THIS. LIKE
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND MARKET
STAFF WILL BE SO PATIENT
WORKING WITH US IN THE COMPASS
CONTACT ME ABOUT. AN EXAMPLE
QUESTION. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
APPRECIATE. YOUR TESTIMONY
CONGRATULATIONS ON. ALL THE
WORK. AND TIME TO COME INTO
THIS. THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO- RETURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
LOOK IN THE CHAMBERS TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
SERGEANTS. LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
NINE AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO
AHEAD TO THE PHONE LINES. ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT OPERATOR ON THE
PHONE LINES AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT IN Q. IF
THERE ARE OTHERS AS A REMINDER
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE TWENTY
THREE. TO THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHERMAN
GRAY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DRUM MACHINE AS TODAY. WOULD
HAPPEN UNITED AUBURN INDIAN
COMMUNITY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE CONTACTED TO THE RIVER
DRIVE. I WOULD LOVE PERSPECTIVE
TAKEN HIS NAME OUT FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK THAT SHE'S DONE ON
THIS. IS A VERY DIFFICULT ONE
THIS IS A LITTLE MORE DETAIL
THAN YOUR NORMAL COMPACT. AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
YOU'VE DONE. I ALSO WANT TO
JUST SAY- THE LEADERSHIP OF
CHAIRMAN CORONA BY SHERMAN
GARFIELD. IT IMPECCABLE IT GOES
WITHOUT SAYING THAT IF IT
WASN'T FOR THE LEADERSHIP AND
LEADERSHIP THE TRIBAL COUNCIL.
THAT WOULD NOT BE ANYWHERE
WHERE THERE ARE TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISSION. ALL
GOOD THE FROM YOU. WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL IN ADDITION. WE DO
HAVE TO TEAR I APOLOGIZE WE'LL
GO TO LINE THIRTY THREE LINE
THIRTY THREE LINE OF THE. THE
TELLER COUNTY SUPERVISOR KYLER
CROCKER THE TULARE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE TULE RIVER TRIBE
EFFORT. NOT ONLY WOULD THAT THE
BAND ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ONE OF THE POOREST COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IT WOULD ALSO
INCREASE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS. JERRY WATER TREATMENT
PLANT WILL HELP WITH OUR LOCAL
WATER NEEDS IN AN AREA THAT
INCLUDES THE INFAMOUS BEAST
PORTABLE WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME ON THE PHONE LINES.
NOT FOR THEIR LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO AHEAD MOVED TO
THE VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
CHARGES DO WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
LOOKS LIKE WE DO NOT. WILL
RETURN TO THE MEMBERS
REPRESSIONS MEMBERS WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS AS IT RELATES TO. THE
TO A RIVER INDIAN TRIBE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE CONTACT
BEFORE US. SEE NO QUESTIONS.
AND HAVING HEARD PUBLIC COMMENT
ANY FINAL CALL HERE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ALL
THANK- MISLABELED- THE THANK
CHAIRMAN- PERONE AND THE- OTHER
CHAIRS WHO HAVE. TESTIFIED HERE
TODAY- IN SUPPORT OF THESE
CONTACTS AS I SAID EARLIER WILL
BE REVIEWED WILL BE BRING THESE
TO THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY
FOR A FORMAL VOTE HERE IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS AS WE CONCLUDE
OUR LEGISLATIVE YEAR- WE THANK-
CERTAINLY. ALL THE TRIBES FOR
THE WORK THAT'S GONE INTO THIS
AS WELL AS THE IN. UNDER
LEADERSHIP OF PRESIDENT MARK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME- A
CONSIDERATION TODAY AND WITH
THAT MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING THIS AFTERNOON THANK
YOU.